what are some of the biggest mistakes
beginning photographers make in setting
up photos not talking they tend to be
too quiet they'll hide behind their
camera they'll they'll they'll sit there
and get so focused and fixated on
details that are to the subject
seemingly unimportant and it's one of
the reasons i recommend a cable release
so you can actually step in front of the
camera you know and be right up next to
them working with them so you're not
hiding and I find a lot of a lot of
younger well not necessarily younger but
you know less experienced people tend to
tend to try to rely on equipment too
much and less about less about their
subject and and and getting to know why
you're actually taking this picture
whether you regardless of subject matter
you